Добрий день телекомпанія дочвеля
німецька хвиля веде пряму трансляцію з
центру Києва Мене звати Микола Берник я
кореспондент дочвеля Зараз ми
знаходимось біля НСК Олімпійського це
головний стадіон країни
і незабаром через 2 по години тут мають
розпочатися дебати кандидатів в
президенти України чинного президента
Петра
Порошенка і шоумена Володимира
Зеленського який є фаворитом цих
президентських перегонів ми бачимо що
тут зібралося вже досить багато
людей очікується це казали в МВС що
подивитися на Президентський батл
прийдуть до 60 000 людей тобто стадіон
буде повним або майже
повним Також тут ми наблюдаємо
безпрецедентні заходи безпеки згідно з
даними нвс порядок Тут будуть охороняти
або охороняють вже 10 тисяч поліцейських
та співробітників над
цгвардії підійти до
олімпійського не просто для цього
потрібно показати паспорт з реєстрацією
у цьому районі або мати посвідчення
журналіста або мати квитки на
дебати Ось але як ми бачимо інтерес до
події
величезний
досить незрозуміло було до останнього
часу чи відбудеться ці дебати взагалі
але зараз сумнівів у тому що кандидати у
президенти України зустрінуться на
Олімпійському немає і інтерес звичайно
підігріває незвичний формат Петро
Порошенко до
останнього наполягав на тому що все ж
таки краще було б зібратися зустрітися
на суспільному телебаченні як це цього
вимагають правила але все ж таки потім
кандидати дійшлися згоди порозуміння І
вирішили зустрітися сьогодні на
головному стадіоні країни Зараз ми
спитаємо людей Звідки вони приїхали чого
вони очікують від цих дебатів і чи чи
здатні сьогоднішні дебати змінити їхню
думку Чи вплинуть вони на їхній вибір
Отже Добрий день скажіть будь ласка
Звідки ви приїхали сюди без
коментарів Ось як ми бачимо не всі
хочуть коментувати дебати Зараз ми
підійдемо до військових наприклад Добрий
день скажіть будь ласка Звідки ви
приїхали доб я не приїхав Я
місцевий славетне місто герой моя
Батьківщина місто Київ Скажіть будь
ласка Чого ви очікуєте від дебатів я
нічого не очікую від дебатів Я очікую що
може після виборів в цій країні
почнуться хоч якісь зміни Можливо на
краще Скажіть будь ласка кого ви
підтримуєте кандидатів нікого я
політичен дякую
вам
Ось як ми бачимо тут є представники не
тільки обох таборів не тільки
прихильники Зеленського та чинного
президента України Петра Порошенка але і
люди які декларують свою аполітичність
Зараз ми
спитаємо Скажіть будь ласка ви місцевий
Ні я з Харкова приїхав Скажіть будь
ласка Чого ви очікуєте від дебатів Ну я
очікую від Володимира зеленців взагалі
хоче якоїсь репрезентації своєї позиції
крім роліків де він кудись біжить
безкінечно і нічого не говорить по
конкретним ключовим питанням від Петра
Порошенка Я хочу аргументованих
відповідей Ну і аргументованих запитань
до його опонента от хотілося б це
побачити тобто Я правильно розумію ви ще
не вирішили кого ви підтримуєте У неділю
я без безперечно підтримую Петра
Порошенка але оскільки частина населення
нашої країни підтримує Зеленського
хотілося б знати взагалі що саме вони
підтримують кого саме вони не
підтримують бо це ж не ну незрозуміло це
якась голограма От і коли вона
перетвориться на хоча б щось на мацальне
Я не знаю От мені хотілося б подивитися
що він взагалі може сказати А скажіть
скажіть будь ласка чи здатні ці дебати
вплинути на ваш вибір на мій особисто
Мабуть ні бо ну з одного боку ми бачимо
досвідченого політика а з іншого боку ми
бачимо людину яка навіть в райраді
ніколи не була депутатом ну тобто Мені
здається що тут немає вибору тобто він
навіть не неочевидний але я думаю на
частину людей це може вплинути
пам'ятаєте от його пряме включення
телефонум де він впав в істерику і кинув
трубку слухавку Мені здається що частина
авдиторії від нього це відсахнуло якщо
він покаже себе Таким чином можливо
частина людей в ньому розчарується ще
більше От я так думаю А на вашу думку на
загальний результат виборів здатні ці
дебати вплинути ще чи я думаю що так
шанси є Ну залежить від того як вони
пройдуть чи будуть обидва кандидати бо
14-го пан Володимир Зеленський не
з'явився на жодні теледебати на якусь Я
не знаю студію не знаю на суспільному ні
на що він не з'являвся тобто людина
ролік І мені хотілося б От якби
дізнатися чи з'явиться він тепер от якщо
з'явиться якщо буде якась предметна
диску нарешті Можливо вони на щось
вплинуть якщо ні Ну дякую вам спасибі
Вам Отже спробуємо спитати ще людей чи є
тут чи є тут прихильники наприклад
Володимира
Зеленського ось нам хочуть відповісти
Добрий день Скажіть будь ласка ви
приїхали сюди звідки Чи ви місцевий
Чернігівська область в чернівсько
області із селища козелиць А скажіть
будь ласка як ви добиралися Тобто
власним транспортом чи вас привезлику на
маршрутку з дружиною сі от значить
приїхали в Київ прийшлися похрещатику
побули на акції де виступав Петро
олесівич Порошенко вот значить і тепер
прийшли там там отримали квитки там є
спеціальні таі Я так поняв палатки І от
значить Зараз ми прийшли сюди Щоб побути
всеж таки бути присутнім на дебатах А
так хотілось би дуже почуть обох
кандидатів і задати можливость якщо така
буде можливість задати питання до обох
кандидатів єсть дуже важливе на мої на
моє глибоке переконання єсть дуже
важливе питання для обох кандидатів
Скажіть будь ласка ви знаєте За кого ви
будете голосувати вже у неділю в першому
турі Ми з дружиною голосували наша
родина голосувала за Порошенка вочить і
в другому турі Скажем так що скажу так
що не помінялись значить погляди во Я
думаю що все ж таки будемо підтримувати
Петра олексівича Порошенка Скажіть будь
ласка все ж таки здатні ціти дебати
вплинути на ваш вибір і ви зміните
можливо рішення своє Так звісно значить
я просто скажу чесно що вже скільки
спостерігав по телебаченню що скільки
вже був на
різних телеканалах Петро олесійвич
Порошенко значить чітко і ясно
відповідає абсолютно ці питання і дійсно
він дивлю дивлячись на нього Я роблю
висновки що він зробив висновки з того
що все ж таки кадрова політика у
його його під час його каденції все ж
таки була провальна тобто дуже багато
негідників все ж таки опинилася в нас
при владі Атака Дякую вам дякую
вам
[музика]
отже як ми бачимо люди кажуть вони вони
з цікавістю прийшли подивитися на ці
дебати але велике питання чи здатні ці
дебати змінити їхні рішення і змінити
також і загальний загальний Результат
голосування яке відбудеться у неділю
наразі за даними соціологічних
досліджень за чинного президента готові
віддати свої голоси менше 30 ві виборців
за Володимира Зеленського який є
фаворитом президентських перегонів
готові проголосувати близько
70%
виборців як ми бачимо тут зібралося вже
досить багато
людей Вони чекають поки їх почнуть
пропускати через кордони поліції це
орієнтовно має початися через півгодини
а самі дебати через 2 по години
З вами була телекомпанія дочвеля дякуємо
за увагу Слідкуйте за нашими
повідомленнями Давайте ми вам
скаже